all right let me explain this is a
segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show why did I try and
do that because we dare them right to
find us making one mistake all right and
we tell them please try and catch us so
far
millions of challengers not one winner
not one mm-hmm well this could end could
end tonight tonight a fan who goes by
the handle filibuster LA County
thanks.thanks he caught a mistake he
says it happened during a segment we did
about money saving tips for the prom I
found another error Conan for high
school seniors prom season quickly
approaching but of course the economy is
still in well it's in a little bit of
rough shape students are on a very tight
budget got those student loans so high
school seniors do not have student loan
got you
[Applause]
[Music]
first of all sir I'm very sorry that
you've been kidnapped yeah yeah
do you know what kind of card is that
you're in yeah yeah I mean it must be a
harrowing experience for you and you
must be running low on oxygen but I'll
tell you something I have to tell you
this you're dead wrong okay you are
wrong there is such a thing as high
school student loans and CNN even did an
investigative report about them
take a look tonight we're going in-depth
on a scan that left more than 500 high
school students in debt
Tamara Walsh has the story the year was
2003 hundreds of unsuspecting teenagers
at this high school were about to get
cheated by a scam artist Doug Wilson
high school everyone wants to look cool
at the time of course nothing was cooler
than vodka chance
Wilson would sell bondage heads at half
the retail price it was a deal that
seemed too good to be true because it
was a couple of days after I bought my
hat I noticed a blue ring around my head
and as much as I showered I couldn't get
it off the hats were counterfeit and
they were turning students heads blue it
happened right before prom
it was a nightmare coincidentally there
was only one clinic in town that could
remove the blue ring run by egg dr. Don
Wilson wasn't covered by insurance I
heard about a long company where I could
get the cash the loan officer signed me
up for a high interest loan the name of
that loan officer you guessed it Dan my
parents hired a malpractice lawyer who
specialized in these cases but
ultimately the judge threw out the case
I'm still paying off those highschool
student loans Wow high school student
loans just devastating up next creeps
with no lights in their houses
the tapper said that you are oh I love
that Jake Tapper yeah always right yeah
all right that settles that the
challenge still stands if you think he's
bought it an era on our show reported at
Tim koco.com slash ha ha I found an
error we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you have what it
takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro we'll take a break when we come
back Norma Donald's here we'll see
yourself
you